ben 201 di happy questi ragazzi sono
tanti tanti tanti episodi abbiamo fatto
la live di 66 ore del pomeriggio l'altra
settimana è stata una bomba e oggi
facciamo il 201o episodio
allora ragazzi come avete visto
nell'episodio 198 e prendiamo gli
episodi normali di epis normali tra
virgolette c'è la versione mobile happy
with della cosa veramente più bella che
io abbia mai visto
vediamo se riusciamo a fare dei livelli
un po più cazzuti perché l'obiettivo di
questo è cercare di portare ogni
personaggio a sbloccare insomma tutti
sui livelli facciamolo partiamo col
padre di uk non ce la farò mai
ovviamente a farli tutti
ma questo happy meals diversamente dagli
altri proprio molto più difficile quindi
normale che ci mette tanto farlo alla
ragazzi vado a cena destra tacco sul
l'ascensore questo qua penso sia
veramente semplice perché il primo
livello di irresponsabile dand che
sarebbe lui ma che ho detto sta cosa
come minimo muoio sei volte però
proviamoci
spero di non far pagare aiuto non è vero
tutto a posto tutto ok il dato della
normale sai quante volte
c'è un posto in più che non ha capito ed
è forse per sganciarmi dalla bici non mi
piaccio così è stato ma cosa sono
cazzate
meno male che un livello dove non muoio
mai allora porco demonio vai veloce e
non trattato primario che era morto non
fate come lo devo andare dietro ancora
vai a posto se lo dice lui come devi
fare cantare non è che penso che il
primo livello sia tipo tutorial sono già
morto due volte però vabbè chissenefrega
finalmente questo quando vedo un po più
difficile giacché network a vacca
giacche e nero questo è veramente
difficile perché i livelli così in
genere sono tarati tipo azzurro easy
giallo di mez medio rosso difficile nero
impossibile però siamo al secondo quindi
deduco che sia ancora fatti prevede
riesca a fare un livello senza mai
morire un modulo detta stack agata veria
porca put a posto a posto forse fissando
la terra mio figlio eccolo lì apposta ma
cosa è finito in gabbia ma cosa aperto
vabbè si sono studiati veramente bene si
cosi porca vacca se si sono sognati bene
raga
meno male tutto a posto
si alza vado perfetto non è vero ma
donna come abus giocatore esperto di
happy questi ragazzi dove la [ __ ] non so
dove sto non so che devo andare la
massima velocità non lo so ok
oddio
ok a posto quindi devo scrivere sì che
mi chiamo ragazzi mi hanno fatto l'hanno
fatto veramente un casino ma perché
hanno fatto diventare un range game
c'è veramente tra questo e fall guys non
so cosa mi fa incazzare di più questo
devo superarlo io che ne so non lo posso
sapere
adesso sto molto più avanti ok in questo
anche perfetto ma ora sono stato bravo
guardare le lucine in realtà non avevo
capito subito va bene cosa faccio dove
vado
aiuto tutto a posto tutto ok
meraviglioso jerk grazie mille fra thank
you ti voglio bene vediamo se lescano
arrivare alla fine di questo vorrei
veramente arrivarci al primo tentativo
il problema ragazze che va veramente a
culo perché anche prima come faceva
sapere quale dei tubi cadeva prima il
quale dopo perché amo e che invece
stavano mica perché sono all'inizio
chissenefrega se muoio però va bene vai
vai vai senza paura senza verdura
let's go pato 18 sbavano sono ancora
vivo però attenzione mi chiami tu che
arrivo al traguardo magari sarebbe stato
fighissimo allora impennata totale
allora perché ci sono delle volte in cui
arriva proprio lento lui cioè non so
come mai la velocità è veramente infima
a ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatto ha
superato il punto di prima
aiuto
[Musica]
ok questa è una cazzata roma dove sono
aiuto queste miniere le miniere le mie
signore degli anelli
raga qua non lo so lo so se stiamo
andando a finire mi sembra un po
eccessivo effettivamente lui mi porti lo
rimanere in bilico
ho sempre l'ansia quando sono nelle
miniere i sotterranei perché chissà che
cacchio vai vai vai me ne sbatto secolo
continua io vado per la mia strada
baugiano una minaccia fosse perché ho
notato che manca la gente in giro c'è di
solito di intervenire negli sono contro
anche altri personaggi e invece qua
manca ci sono solo percorsi a ostacoli
che figo è molto figo come un impossible
misto a un rock swing c'è un po di roma
però mancano i personaggi porca vacca
manca proprio quello quanti cacchio ce
ne sono visti cosi a posto
meno male non c'era un altro morto di
nuovo aiuto l'oro non solo che sta
andando un minuto dvd di livello già non
ho idea di dove va bene avere difficile
un giro gratis grazie
meno male non c'erano mi si è rotta la
bici ma che cacchio ma veramente a me
tutte a me vado con l'oro davanti gli
sticazzi perfetto tutto ok come
traguardo vi prego senza una ruota va
bene non importa va bene così
l'importante è arrivarci bello che
mettono anche gli ostacoli posti a
livello mi piace però next
male che forse non sono mai partito così
male però fa niente madonna sta arrivato
ok non prometteva chissà quanto bene suo
livello proprio sulla famiglia sono così
via
la miope pape è crollato tutto a posto
non andare di qua perfetto non è anche
capito che se succede vabbè aiuto
crollano le cose da fare sotto il giro
un meno male che c'è oggi mi fai va dal
traguardo che c'è un'ansia pazzesca per
favore per favore ti prego
il traguardo è tuttora lenti minchia
patcher e vabbè vabbè c'è una voce o
pazzesco come ho fatto attivare lo sono
a si attiva da solo bellissimo
si chiama che incredibile gioco è
diventato è più varia dallo schifo a
dalla perfezione cosa faceva sfiderà
nostro gioco tra vent'anni quando sarò
ancora qui a giocare a ping e che devo
fare qua sul muro era un vabbè c'è un
acquario a posto non è vero
riproviamo devi devi andare veloce
troverà questo qua non perdona niente ne
ho capito cosa devo fare bene così io
sono andato veloso fatto perfetto e non
è un gioco meritocratico sta merda che
io l'ho fatto veramente perfetto ragazzi
cioè che giuro
sono andato avanti alla velocità della
più di così non potevo fare più di così
non potevo fare ma ci riprovo
ammazzatevi ci ho provato veramente ci
ho messo tutto il cuore l'anima nella
pedala ero io che pedalavo porco demonio
e ancora non vi va bene niente ma of
amici di provare che cacchio sono
impegnatissima ragazzi proviamo l'ultimo
aiuto l'ultimo una volta sola perché la
vedo abbastanza difficile devo stop armi
non mi dovevo scappare
pezzo di merda se riesco a fare
veramente l'ultimo anche se la vedo
troppo difficile devo andare 18 però
possiamo stare anche tutti calmi sono
vivo sono vivo io sono vivo a posto a
posto apposta posta continua a scendere
che della mia vita è questa la mia vita
fatta di casini e basta ok sono volato
giù
non capisco niente sto morendo
[Musica]